[Musique]
pourquoi tu as arrêté la musique qui
veut jouer à buddy's body's
est-ce que quelqu'un a du réseau
par chialer
alors on joue comment un thriller
décapant et hilarant si tu tires le bout
de papier sur lequel il y a un X tué le
meurtrier tous les autres joueurs
doivent éviter de se faire tuer
des anxiolytiques t'en veux sauvage
mordant et profondément drôle
notre ami David est mort alors s'il te
plaît évite d'aggraver la situation ça
gratte rien du tout c'est toi qui tiens
à soi et qui arrête pas de gesticuler un
rebondissement qui vous tient en haleine
ce serait trop évident si j'étais le
meurtrier ta vie quoi explosif
incroyable assez toujours en train de
faire du gaslighting vous êtes nocif
pour moi
de dire ce que je veux dire qui définit
toute une génération
je viens vraiment de tirer sur moi
j'arrive pas à croire que tu oses te
ramener à toi
quels argument tu peux mettre sur la
table juste je projette l'image d'un
gars qui baise tu me suis je donne
l'impression que je baise et c'est ça
l'image que je veux projeter tu vois